let me ask you a different question let
me ask you a different question a
serious question okay i'm a 22 year old
kid listening to this i'm a driven guy i
want to do big things forget about the
guy that's not ambitious that doesn't
want to do anything with his life and he
just wants to kick back you don't need
to tell him you couldn't motivate the
guy even if you brought all the best
motivational speakers in the room i'm a
22 year old kid i really want to do
something big with my life
we're all in our 30s and 40s here and
some of us are maybe not in our 40s and
30s but
in the room here you get you can give
this advice to somebody at 20 20 22
years old what would you tell this kid
eat clean about drugs what would you
talk about drugs
stick to the natural stuff what would
you what would you tell them about drugs
look uh i've done drugs i've done
i grew up in south beach i've done uh i
i'm not if i always tell this story that
the only reason i'm alive right now is i
don't like cocaine i mean everyone in
miami is cocained out and that's how
they reason they they party i would say
this
um
get your [ __ ] done focus on what is
actually important like work
get your you know but if if you're doing
well and you want to go out on the
weekends
again i think smoking a joint is way
better than getting wasted and just
taking a fifth to the head on alcohol
your 18 year old son you're going to
tell him that
i would say i'd rather him smoke a joint
then drink a liter of alcohol you're
okay with them smoking without 18.
they're going to do it anyway real talk
i mean how many
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute hang on a second wrong assumption
you didn't do it until you were out of
college right correct okay so you when
you say they're going to do it anyways
we don't know that i'm saying what would
you say gerard what would you say uh i
think
dude unfortunately man i think this is
one of those things where people need to
touch the stove to realize how hot it is
like every time i did drugs every time i
got drunk every time i got messed up i
didn't have a bad time but every time i
had the worst night of my life i was
high or i was i was drunk or i was
messed up so it's not like every time
you do something you ruin your life but
every time you ruin your life you're on
some [ __ ] you know you know what's so
you know what's the thing i would say is
the following here's the one thing
here's i remember i can tell you crystal
clear
every single time where i was at when a
kid said here smoke a cigarette i said i
don't want to smoke a cigarette my mom
and dad smoke two packs a day every day
from the day i was born in our house in
our car everybody smoked two packs a day
two packs a day okay in iran okay
so we've been a carnal white renault mom
and dad are smoking cigarettes the whole
you know what the hotbox and stuff i
mean we've been around i had secondhand
uh uh brutal
ask my dad the story look what he'll
tell you you're saying hot boxing
cigarettes
out the window down nose
it's not just my parents it's not just
my parents remember remember in
airplanes they used to have uh ashtrays
and you're saying back now with vapes
you go into a bar and down in the heart
here's what i'm gonna tell you so so
that was cigarettes that that was a he
liked his alcohol he every day he drank
a glass like this of a uh
i don't know how you describe what oh he
is 60 i mean it was 60 proof it's legit
stuff that you're talking about okay
so uh
and you guys know how much i love my dad
so this isn't something he would tell
you these stories himself right okay go
to high school i see guys smoking
cigarettes i'm like i'm good guys you
guys smoke cigarettes i've had the
chance to smoke cigarettes since i was
six months old you guys i've probably
been smoking more cigarettes and both of
you guys combined so
then the wheat situation comes out you
want to smoke weed i'm good
then the the the other couple of the
situations comes up one time i was about
i was a uh i don't know if i've told the
story here
uh i'm working at valleys this one guy
that's working there
he's always got these s-500s parked
outside he's got a boat he's got a yacht
but he never sells memberships and he's
a sales person selling drugs he's making
6.75 an hour i'm like how the hell
so one day i'm like i don't want to say
the guy let's say his name is michael
very good friend tyler david no let's
say his name is michael one day i say
michael can we go to quiz zones we go he
would never let me pay
i'm like dude you're not making money
i said let me go dude i got you you're
cool it says no this house it doesn't
love the pickle bar yeah so he's yeah
i'd go to quiz oh so he says i said i
said i got you pete don't worry about it
so he pays for 10 years older than me i
said dude michael how the hell you make
all this money
he said what are you doing this saturday
i said i'm open he said let's go
somewhere so we go saturday
introduce me to the top uh uh uh what do
you call it cocaine dealer in l.a
colombian guy so i meet him then he says
let's go we go to the back how much
money are you making
i said dude i'm i'm the top sales guy in
my office i'm making 3 500 bucks a month
i'm killing it he starts laughing he
says you're making 3 500 bucks a month
how'd you like to make four grand a week
because you're a pretty big guy i said
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm all in 4 000 a week he
says yeah says here's all i need you to
do i need you to be our muscle and help
us get the money okay from our guys that
haven't paid
as a matter of fact what are you doing
right now
i said uh nothing it's like one o'clock
in the morning let's go to marina del
rey we got to collect some money he says
but before we do i want you to test the
product so he takes me to the bathroom
he says test the product i do a line
that night
i come out i said
there is no freaking way i can get close
to this thing i thought i was king kong
on steroids i said get this thing yeah
away from this guy right so we went that
night
we collected a hundred thousand dollars
that night with uh this this one guy on
the marina anyways this is like 23 20
i'm 19 years old 20 years old on
[Laughter]
anyways we leave we come out
and he says so now you know i don't sell
any
memberships i said i i think i kind of
got an idea i'm making 10 or 20 a week
selling this
next week i go to work he says you want
to make another four grand i said no bro
i don't even want the money i stepped
away
here's a moral of the story what i'm
telling you i've been in it i've seen it
i've been around it
every single one of my friends that even
got close to any kind of drugs x special
k
lsd go through craig do any one of them
you want to talk about every single one
of my friends that even got close to
drugs lost years of their life they lost
momentum
they got fired they lost friendships
they lost girlfriends they lost loved
ones they committed suicide best friends
died because the guy started off with
weed it went to alcohol it went to
cocaine it went to heroin it went to 50
vicodins every day until he died
on may of 2005 and when i got the phone
call i was on a drive to diamond bar and
i have to give a speech that afternoon
it was the most emotional speech
everyone was looking at me saying why
are you saying much i'm leagues i have
no clue what just happened this guy just
passed away
i didn't want to talk about it but i was
a keynote speaker moral the story
if you have big plans and you want to do
something big
don't even think about getting close to
drugs there was a guy in
canada that we were doing business with
insurance guy this guy was making three
million a year
married
killing it
so all of a sudden he gets invited to
all these celebrity parties in canada
but he's a simple guy he was married to
his wife high school sweetheart
everything was good so he gets invited
to these parties
cool parties he starts getting minded to
these cool poker games like oh my gosh
i'm not playing poker with these
hollywood stars with these athletes
well one thing leads to another starts
picking up cocaine everybody runs them
doing drugs he starts doing drugs
he loses his business he loses his wife
he loses his kids six months later he's
homeless in the streets people are
seeing this guy he lost every single
penny his family had his wife at all of
it's wiped out ruined the entire family
just because he got caught up and this
guy is not in his 20s he wasn't in his
30s he was in his early 40s this [ __ ]
can't get you no matter how old you are
yeah they they got to be very very very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very
very very very very very very very good guys
like that like they they see guys like
that a mile away man like he was a mark
like somebody who was setting up those
poker games was like well we're just
going to get him a couple chicks around
here they all have money though it
wasn't like he was partying with your
money becomes my money that's how i make
my money that's that's that's how that
works but it wasn't even that they saw
him a mile away yeah but it wasn't even
that it's not when you're around other
money people they're not they're just as
big sometimes as idiots as you are like
they're just trying to recruit more
people that want to party with you
they're not trying to steal the money
from you but you want to if you're
putting that to if you're putting that
table together you're putting that risk
together i promise you they're they're
looking for a room
say a guy like that is out there all i'm
saying to you is this was not a playboy
you know how you talk to a guy you know
this guy's his name you you you
interviewed her first yeah absolutely
come on you know what i'm trying to tell
you is of course what i'm trying to tell
you
this guy was not a player you know how
you talk to a guy around girls like i
remember when adam said this adam's like
oh gerard and i went out let me tell you
man gerard's pretty good with the ladies
he's pretty calm okay i mean yeah how
long did it take you to realize the
guy's going to be comfortable with her
two two days
and stole the girl i was talking to him
but you ever go hang out with a guy and
all of a sudden like dude this guy is
awkward or wrong you ever met a god
that's this guy was the awkward i don't
want to say anything yeah so
you know anybody that's awkward or no so
here's the thing i'll say all right and
this is the truth and this has been my
reality with this because i i've i have
so many friends that have experienced
exactly what you just described man and
i it's a it's an escape from reality so
when you talk to your kids and stuff
like that where you can tell them don't
do drugs don't do this don't do that if
they're broken inside if something's
happened to them where spiritually
they're broken depression's a real thing
i don't know what happened with this guy
maybe he climbed the mountain this is
something i'm seeing that i never would
have expected at this stage in my life
my friends who have kind of like quote
unquote made it they get depressed for
having made it they love the chase they
feel like they have no purpose anymore
that's when they start the party and
they do all this other [ __ ] i swear to
god i have no way to
to quantify this but i thought about
this when i was in the minors i would
see guys start doing stupid things
and i'd be like they're doing this on
purpose because they're giving
themselves an out because it's an
incredibly hard thing to be like i
didn't make it because i just wasn't
good enough that's a hard ass thing to
come to tournaments look in the mirror
but now to be able to be like oh man if
i just stopped drinking oh man if i
didn't get hooked on the candy and then
you give yourself that little bit of out
that it wasn't me right and i i swear i
see it now you got guys 40 years old
they're married they've got the mansion
they got but like life is kind of like
it's kind of flatlined for them and they
need to see it destroyed because they
want to see if they can build it back up
again there's something inside of them
that has this self-destructive
compulsion and as far as the kids
you know
you talk about that awkward being
socially anxious you talk about like a
guy who goes to a bar there's a kid who
goes to a bar i can't talk to a girl i
don't have the the confidence unless i'm
drunk unless i'm high right it's a
pretty easy thing to go up to liquid
courage more than that you go up to a
girl in miami these girls are beautiful
it's hard to you know but it's like hey
i got a bump you want to go to the
bathroom it's like boom break the ice or
we're going we go to a party and it's
like a socially acceptable way to break
that ice and it's that gets the guys
aren't hooked on coke they're not hooked
on whiskey they're not hooked on weed
they're hooked on that culture because
that's how they identify totally being
able to get in you know so like when you
talk to kids and when you have these
conversations it's not about like don't
do it or else it's like dude you have to
figure out a way to be confident in
yourself and take care of your spiritual
and your mental well-being
so you're not susceptible to these
things you hit the nail on the head with
the cocaine thing because i've been
there i've seen it everywhere it's a
party drug people it's a social joke hey
you know it's cool it's sneaky let's go
in the bathroom or whatever
the one thing i will say i
wholeheartedly agree with everything you
said about the drugs the pills the
popping ev you know the the the only
thing that i'll say is with the
marijuana nobody's overdosed on
smoking joints never in the history of
the world oh yeah you know so you have
people that are like
bill maher is a huge wheat advocate he
says vocally i smoke joe rogan i mean
elon musk on his podcast there's people
out there that definitely use the
creative benefits medicinal benefits
there's two different conversations here
the one conversation is should it be
legalized i'm a libertarian you want to
do whatever hell you want to do to your
body do it i'm just telling you it's
going to slow you down i agree with you
if you've got big ambitions if you want
to do something big with your life stay
the hell away from drugs and alcohol
if you have big ambitions you want to do
something big with your life stay the
hell away from drugs and alcohol that's
my feedback i agree now the person can
do whatever they want to do with their
uh their lives that's up to them as my
grandmother would say pat you can't fly
with the eagles in the morning if you're
out with the owls at night oh
[Music]
you can't soar with the eagles in the
morning if you're out with the owls at
night why does your grandma sound like
mike you just need enough cocaine i
think at a certain age everybody because
are you saying owls do cocaine is that
what you're saying
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]